so you [ __ ] you uh you got
invited out to the McDonnells
headquarters right yes this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's so it's you know what it's
getting to the point now where I just
think they're doing it on purpose to
piss me off because there's absolutely
no [ __ ] way that I should not have
been invited by now I'm like okay so I
think recently Casey got a deal yeah
what the [ __ ] but it's it's from a
different group I don't yes so the group
that brought out Gina is the same group
that brought me out and then Barton geo
hasn't got one either and they will
Julia hasn't got one either
and I don't know ever I mean I asked him
about it too but I mean I was hand
selected so I mean no you know what it
is like a fine jewel you know what it
would it what it was I did a lot of free
promo for them before yeah so like you
know after everybody was like sponsor JK
for their Instagram right um they you
know a couple months ago they sent me
like a bunch of gift cards in like they
gave me some like like letters and
envelopes and like I never even got that
promo to instantly right yeah well they
gave me that stuff to just start giving
to people and then they sent me like a
365 like booklet of a bunch of free like
gifts and I just started giving so much
to people that I think like I was just
on the radar because I put in work for
them I put in work to get free [ __ ] like
I just kept you know I'm gonna put in a
word for you because what I ended up
doing was I asked them like hey you know
JK has a bigger audience and I was like
why don't you you know that would be
better if we do a JK news you know if
David so did you see do you see this man
I lost weight on McDonald's you know
what though
I was actually the biggest one they're
like really well they were bringing in
different people like in waves and then
most of them were food bloggers and
stuff like food Instagram and you know
this was just a strictly Instagram
problem you see this what I'm saying
like I am everything I I'm a food guy
yeah I also have great content and I
have like a million subscribers like oh
what else do you [ __ ] want I own
restaurants like I promote the [ __ ] you
know what this is what it is jackin
the-box what's up yeah
no I shouldn't say that I just just
throw me anything I don't get throw me
up give me a [ __ ] head you know what
I'm I think they're saving the best for
last
then and there they're just working up
the steps is what's what's happening I
want them to give me a McDonald's pen so
I could write my feelings on a piece of
McDonald's paper that's all I want I'm
not even asking for much more
recognition they're literally doing the
thing where they just they're doing it
to everybody else around me because they
know it bothers me and it's getting
under my skin that's what it is you know
they they watch our stuff like they
thought they thought it was hilarious
like like you know yeah they get
bombarded though you know what it's it's
not McDonald's directly yeah like they
have agencies that take care of their
marketing well so marketing yeah bucks
look at me dude I love you guys thanks
for the thanks for the opportunity and I
would love you to if you give me the
same opportunity I am a food food fat
ambassador
I'm a fat ambassador you know it's crazy
they have a restaurant like just to do
filming in slowly so this they have this
huge building right it's like I don't
know like 15 floors or whatever it's
huge and then the bottom floor is like
this it's like a regular McDonald's but
it has like international products at
the rotate so when I was there they had
like matcha matcha latte dad like all
kinds of different stuff good matcha
latte so you got you got the sample [ __ ]
that nobody else had well that they have
that in Japan so sometimes like yeah so
sometimes they'll have things from
Australia like the shaker fries or
whatever or like you know they'll just
bring in different products she's out
there living my damn good and then and
then I was at the hamburger University
where they train all of their like
hamburger specialists what's it like to
be human I just got to go there get the
sample all these treats and then they
have a restaurant built in just for
filming
so really yeah and then I think that's
like the test place where they teach all
the franchise owners like how to like
work the registers and like the system
like the kitchen and all that stuff
really yeah and they they use that for
filming - what the [ __ ] is hamburger
University
well hamburger University is their
school like when you're a franchisee
the golden ruler comes out and [ __ ]
professor hamburger yeah [ __ ] no like
they just come out and then they I guess
like once you own a franchise you got to
learn how to run it you got a you know
they want you to be less like
franchising schools what they teach you
how the system is a yeah yeah do you
know how much it cost of franchising
McDonald's I don't know but I think you
could check out on entrepreneur comm and
last time I checked like ten years ago
it was like you have to have a million
dollars so it's a seven-figure franchise
yeah like not only a million dollars in
assets but like a million dollars cash
or something like that what the like it
was it was some big amount of money I
was like I was like nah this is too much
it's crazy I mean pretty sure because
it's like a definite that it's going to
do well yeah I've never seen in
McDonald's closed down unless like a
homeless person I lit it on fire which I
did see once yeah you're right I haven't
seen anything Donald's closed down yeah
I've never seen the McDonald's closed
down because it wasn't successful I've
only seen it get burnt down that's it
yeah
it's crazy man I mean what I love about
it is like they're consistent with their
product and that's hard to do yeah well
it's easy to make trash consistent I'm
kidding
it's trash to everybody else but it's
not trash to me it's golden nuggets it's
just bitter no but that's what it is
it's not like this is why I get so upset
when people when also for example like I
was out in Miami for scent foods yeah
and we were shooting and then the sound
guy was like we stopped by and and we're
we're going on the way back we didn't
have enough time to get the crew a meal
so we're like yo whatever you guys want
to eat just let us know so we can give
you a quick bite before we stop off and
those McDonald's yeah and then she was
like oh there's a McDonald you guys just
wants to be quick he goes what that's
you want to feed a sawdust on the hold
on [ __ ] what you mean something you was
saying one guy I was like what you mean
Saada son Wow [ __ ] the disrespect I've
never heard at first of all to called us
I think like the perception of like fast
was so weird they go oh that's not real
food then what the [ __ ] am i [ __ ]
out of my ass that's some real [ __ ] you
better shut the [ __ ] up with that you
know people expect I don't know what
they expect from a fast-food joint you
know they go right this is do you know
what it does to your body there's a lot
of bad things like just because you the
snicker you wait at home this terrible
just your body to the microwave dinner
you ain't I mean it's like it's
different levels
yeah the hot cheetos you just ate - it's
not any what's the damn difference yeah
I think what do they expect like some
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay ass like super or
steamed food or that's what I'm saying I
know what McDonald's is for if I want to
get a 99 cents officer of Kohn and some
chicken nuggets and some fries I know
where to get real quick it's a snack I
mean it's not meant to be like you know
you eat it three times a day
exactly any fast food any fast food yeah
I'm saying it's there to just enjoy from
time to time and like they even they
even say that too like it's like please
don't promote like gluten II like I mean
like just good any like just massively
eating and stuff it's like it's not you
know really meant to be that kind of
stuff
of course yeah that's one saying well
you know what's cool though you know
what's cool is that they have so they
have they're like chefs that are like
the inventors they have chefs yeah so
they sit down and like so I got to taste
like what a chicken nugget what a you
know quarter like quarter pounder like
what are these supposed to taste like
made by the best of the best and no
doesn't eat of Todd's dude even when
it's cold like we were just sitting
there mind blown like how is this it's
like perfectly fried perfectly
everything and in the meat that they use
at the headquarters they use like this
like prime like Oh me I mean it's it's
the guys it's it's like different yeah
it's like prime meat like it's good mean
so I was just like wow dude this is
crazy like so what they create in that
kitchen that they're trying to replicate
that in mass production yes but I think
the difference is it was fresh yeah so
like if you've noticed like when you go
to a regular you know McDonald's right
down the street or whatever right
sometimes the fries aren't good
sometimes they're good there's there's a
difference I mean there's a slight
difference and it's because the fries
were fresh more like you know it was
just made right now yeah so I think when
you try it when it's made at that moment
it tastes so damn good yeah you get
lucky sometimes with McDonald's french
fries every dollar has your favorite yep
did you know you can ask them to make it
fresh what you can ask them yeah I want
a fresh batch it'll be like okay well
we're gonna make a new one or they're
like okay we just made one or you could
wait a little bit yeah yeah I didn't
know that right no [ __ ] clue that's
[ __ ] wild yeah
it's like a secret that's crazy dude yes
I was out and um because when you were
doing that I remember that day you flew
out and then I flew out to Florida what
were you at Miami